next up em so easy hope I pronounced
that okay he's saying he designed smart
homes he's saying he agrees that when
he's working in b2c market all they want
to hear about as a story and why he
created his business when he's selling
to builders and his in b2b all they care
about is price they don't care about a
story all they care about is offering
something cheap how do I overcome this I
want to make more money selling b2b yeah
i think it's the case a little bit in
some even in houses I think there's kind
of blurring between kind of b2b and b2c
and yeah everybody wants to store in
terms of big you know you think about
you're gonna buy a house it's your dream
isn't it especially if it's your first
house I can remember the day we walked
in until the keys on our first house and
I still remember as if i'm there today
how it just kind of thought wow you know
what a sense of responsibility did I
really make this this is my own place
you know and and the level of the clean
rooms the the Hoover and all that sort
of stuff went up through the sky now
builders obviously they've got an
economic model they've got to make money
they've got to be profitable and in that
business kind of builders can live
hand-to-mouth they've got a lot of
subcontractors they've got a lot of
people that need pay like every week and
a lot of their payments in that business
are staged on kind of milestones of
completion of building the house so I
think you have to be sensitive to that
but also I don't know anybody in
business and builders are the same they
don't want to do a great job they want
to build great houses they want to they
want to make people proud and that's the
story you could connect to wis because
so that not only you know great house
builders get talked about in communities
that everybody wants one of their houses
and it's no good you know when they go
to the golf club or a dinner party or
kind of some sort of chat room and
they'll be there and someone will say
something awesome about that house that
was built by then they will be swelling
up with pride so I would find the story
that connects to them being very
cognizant that they have to make money
out of it and the sensitivity of you
standing in their shoes
and to Evans point of going where the
audiences with a builder and understand
their business model and it's very kind
of cash constrained and they got to kind
of make money and that comes down to
cutting costs it but more than that
everybody I know everybody who's an
entrepreneur and everybody's dialed into
this yeah you want to do things great
few customers you want to do things in
terms of treating the company's money as
if it's your own and making sure every
expense dollar gets her kind of return
on investment but more than that you
want to do it the right way you want to
build awesome products you want to build
awesome awesome houses I think the
echoes Stevens Point from the very top
of the show as long as you're dealing
with a human stories matter people care
people are guided by their emotions they
want to feel connected to you now not
every customer will be able to afford
what you're doing right if you're if
you're dealing with a high end product
and you're dealing with very price
sensitive customers they may love your
story but it doesn't mean they can
afford it right the stuff that I do ah
not everybody can afford it and that's
fine so I think I don't think the story
hurts you but it's not everything right
like the stories is not going to the
story will win some clients over that if
there's a credit of situation you'll get
the business but you also have to give
them a good business case right if you
have a bad product or your you are to
overprice the story is not going to be
enough just to get you over that hurdle
so I think it's just understanding
understanding your customer base I would
I would disagree that all b2b people
only care about price I think there's a
lot of emotion that goes into every
business deal that happens just looking
at my own business I get opportunity to
work with a lot of different companies
and brains and the ones that I say yes
to are the ones that I connect with the
leadership and their story and what that
are all about and I think they connect
with me because of my store when i'm all
about and it's not just hey can you do
it for a thousand dollars cheaper and
then that's what you know mix the mix
the shift as long as you're doing with
people stores are going to be important
whether you're selling to customers in
the b2c space or b2b space i have it i
think on that as well the power what you
said
it's when your story becomes the
audience's story and the connection
between your story and this is where the
heart kind of kicks in I I don't know
and a story could be a question as well
so if you asked a house builder how did
you feel when you took the keys to your
first apartment or your first house that
individual will go back 20 30 years ten
years and the emotions will flood in and
secondly I think it's really important I
don't know any house builder if you ask
them the question what was the first
house that you built how did that feel I
guarantee they put the best taps on they
would have been really proud of the
house they would have wanted that has to
be the best house the best home
experience that was on the planet and
they'll remember that first house they
bill just like as an entrepreneur I
remember the first sale i made i
remember the first customer we had I
remember the first employee we hired
because those things connect your heart
totally and your head in your memory and
you get flooded with emotion and that's
the way you unlock the human